I'm Greg I'm Anita welcome to the real
reject welcome to the relief how are you
I'm very well are you asking me I'm
asking that yes it's not rhetorical and
they can't work on back you can in the
comic so we won't see it until later yes
that true that so doing that thing right
now you know where people are like this
person requests it is their name hear
the comments like that ah this is some
requested Anthony tanza he's the first
one metric ton press I not a requested
this it's a trailer for this movie
called the assignment all right it stars
on Michelle Rodriguez so you might open
the fat in the Furious movie she's
amazed for Gorney Weber you might know
from the alien movies and it's directed
by this director who awesome films like
an alleged ahead Last Man Standing
another 48 hours so you know there's
gonna be a solid fill ya trick you can
call me the doctor this operation is
your reminder the terrible thing you did
this is your opportunity for redemption
[Music]
what yeah to me Frank
Frank look a little different and how
you do the job
come online again why me the doctor
wanted you I wanted to call it Frank
kitchen in Mormon
[Music]
the time of trouble teen life he wasted
[Music]
there's anything left the frame kitchen
with his point-blank aim ha
[Music]
I going to get you
[Music]
she's wearing the exact outfit from the
machete movies Wow following and hates
assassin it was double-crossed by
gangsters and fall to the hands of rogue
surgeon as the doctor returns it into a
woman what an interesting ideas aren't
interesting I mean is there been
anything like this before where the
punishment is it sexy yeah yeah seems to
work out all right for her but I'm
walking very original it's an action
movie but it doesn't really seem to play
on the psychology of a man turning your
woman against its own will yeah that's
the best sex change operation anyone's
ever asked for you know yeah I mean I'm
all for what are those rights they call
them women that's what will the cup
women's rights when a man and a woman
I'm okay to call him a woman after that
i'm not going to object against that but
i just don't think a lot of them end up
looking like that sexy have you seen GG
gorgeous that's really [ __ ] nevermind
nevermind in devaluing honest reaction
yeah yeah are you kidding me really Oh
God Oh beautiful well beautiful like
drop-dead gorgeous Oh cantore I in fact
I take me back then I gotta look up more
of gender sample look at all the time
you might be my new thing now meet me
might be my new market what I liked
about this is that the women roles in
this we're really strong like you got
Sigourney Weaver who's a badass Michelle
Rhee guess who's a badass and like
putting them both in a movies like
strong female roles it just looks like
it's going to work really well I would
just like it if it I mean it seems like
this person this dude it's probably how
would do is know who is in this assam
ago about if you turn me into a woman
now i'm gonna go chill wit yeah yeah
it's funny because in the beginning you
kind of get that like walking dead vibe
where you wake some heat she wakes up in
like a hospital and it's like what the
[ __ ] is happening type of thing yeah
that was interesting maybe they'll play
on that and then like Michelle Rodriguez
is character kind of finds out what's
happening and like what is going on
on and that's kind of the journey we go
on yeah I think it would be a cool movie
if she is someone who wants the surgery
to be big he's like you terminate a
woman feels like I was not volunteering
I would like it to be something where
maybe she's going out I don't know if
you deal with this psychology yeah it
doesn't feel like it's dealing at all
with this icon this idea bout ya from
the trailer you don't see that the movie
new action movie yeah but maybe when you
actually watch the movie it's going to
go into the psychology then again it
does look like a b-movie kind of actions
don't litter poison about the psychology
or just like you don't belong here [ __ ]
man turn into a woman now wants revenge
making out yeah yeah it seems like
things are down really well / hey why
not her girlfriend is like [ __ ] it
you're a woman now all it just make it I
like that it's very open minded well
done and asking a lot la piccola do you
remember him I don't know that is this
guy he was him without a trace he was in
that vampire movie innocent hug oh yeah
that guy didn't owe the client yeah yeah
he's from Australia you never knew that
fun set for you and I really have
commentary on yeah this looks like it
could be a really fun action movie think
it will call this kind of a different
concept than you're used to Michelle
Rodriguez has always been the tomboyish
type she pulled that she'll take on this
oscar-worthy trend gender room like
that's a sexy tomboy time yeah I like
the girl that you like my hot way hot
lesbian tomboy but you just like man I
wish she liked penis you know
yeah I wish you did too well I mean I
don't have to rush my shadow oh i think
i'm good just where i need to be a butt
crush we crush your sack is that need
something you're into the funny term
yeah crush my sack does it derives from
anywhere possibly but you know not
telling me what then i had a very
interesting childhood if you're new this
channel you can subscribe to the real
research subscribe to the real reject i
needed stars they need a stargazer
channel I'd be a new star channel it
stars in channels and Anita's good
usually a new video every one monday
Monday oh you know scheduling attention
a word you say sometimes sometimes not
always sometimes and shout out to
Anthony for being the first one to the
video tanza and Anthony Tarzan Tiffany
stars in well you probably i think i'll
offer that name panda people with so
many tours in God you feel no not
projecting my childhood
[Music]